the biden transition team is pushing
back against president trump's latest
rhetoric about the election
this is the president-elect moves full
steam ahead with another round of
cabinet announcements expected
next week nicole killian is traveling
with the president-elect in rehoboth
beach delaware good morning nicole
good morning to you michelle and
president-elect biden has spent the last
couple of days here at his beach home
with family he has no public events
today
but his team is dismissing the
president's
rejected lawsuit as desperate and
embarrassingly meritless while also
disputing
the president's latest election fraud
claims a transition official tells cbs
news
quote president-elect biden won 306
electoral votes states continue to
certify those results
and the electors will not
sue the elector the lectors will soon
meet to ratify that outcome joe biden
will be sworn in on january 20th 2021
and shortly thereafter
he'll enter the white house as the duly
elected president of the united states
now over the thanksgiving break the
president-elect and his wife dr jill
biden
spoke with front-line health care
workers they also continue to urge
americans to do their part
during the pandemic whether it's wearing
masks social distancing
or limiting family gatherings the
president-elect is also gearing up to
nominate more people to serve in key
posts within his administration
this week he announced his national
security team and
next week he will roll out his economic
team although the transition would not
specify
which positions mr biden intends to fill
now the president-elect and
vice president-elect will also get their
first
presidential daily brief on monday after
president trump
signed off on it earlier this week dana
all right nicole we promise we will send
ed back to you soon we won't keep them
for too long thank you
yeah ed i'm sorry we're gonna we'll
eventually send you back because you're
too valuable out there
everything that's gone on not just in
the election but the lead-up and
everything
i know you've been asked about this a
lot but is there a way to sum up just
what this has been like compared to
other years oh this is
you can't compare this year at all to
years past uh between what's going on
right now and what went on just with the
fact that they couldn't campaign
in person most of the time across the
country so you know this is this is
going to be one that we set apart i
think from
most of the others and we'll see but you
know it's it's fascinating to see this
continue
and it's telling that the judges
continue to tell the trump team they
have no merit
uh in the claims that they've been
making and there's no end in sight
really i mean the question is
what's going to happen with the
inauguration and beyond with
a new administration yeah well and the
fact that the president said look you
know once the electors vote in
the december i'll probably see we'll see
about
uh going to the inauguration itself i
think that's one thing people should
prepare for that that is likely to be a
very different looking
event this year not just because the
president may or may not show up but
just by virtue of the fact that
you don't want to be holding large super
spreader events well nothing bigger than
an inauguration that could bring
hundreds of thousands of people to
washington so
i suspect soon we're going to hear that
they're announcing a more scaled back
affair we keep saying 2020 but
that continues into 2021. it does we
have to continue to be safe